congratulations honoree tonight how does
it feel to be honored for being yourself
oh my gosh it's apps I I don't have the
words to even like I'm like so honored
it's like so amazing all of these
amazing people yeah I'm here with my
gorgeous wife she looks amazing tonight
I haven't even like processed it yet so
well you deserve it you're doing a lot
of cool stuff in the entertainment space
of course one of the pop culture moments
of 2022 was your unbelievable wedding
congratulations five months in does it
feel different
um it does feel different you know like
I think like you know I married my best
mate and it's the best feeling in the
world and you know it's just me and her
we do our own thing we work we both work
like every day we all keep busy but you
know it's absolutely the best and yeah I
love it I love that you told variety
that you think Nicola is hilarious and
the world should see it with a reality
show oh my gosh so I'm I'm definitely a
yes for that I want to see that are
there conversations about that maybe
happening how does Nicola feel I mean I
mean to be honest like we always have a
laugh we always talk about the most
ridiculous things we love each other's
company
um you know I'm never gonna say never
you never know
um but probably not not not soon I'm
just focusing on my cooking you know
trying to make a like a name for myself
aren't you I hope so that's that's my
dream to open up my own little Pub uh my
local pub so yeah
do that look that's something we could
explore on a reality show and I gotta
tell you I think doing a reality show
you get to sort of control the narrative
yeah and when I think of you and Nikola
I think of classy you guys are just so
classy the way that you handle
everything people say things do things
how do you guys manage tuning out the
noise and just kind of staying true to
who you are does it bother you ever
um I think like it gets time to like get
used to it like obviously like it's not
the best thing to see people writing not
the nicest of things but you know we
have each other we have out each other's
back more than anything
um so I think we've just both learned so
don't listen to that just keep working
and there's always going to be people to
not write the nicest of things but but
you guys stay focused on the positive
exactly how do you feel about expanding
the family I know you said you're kind
of into it Nicola needs a minute have
you guys had conversations about a
timeline or where you see that happening
um I I've always wanted to be a young
Dad it's like been my dream yeah and you
know as I said before I found my best
mate you know and I would love to I
would love to have a family soon but
whenever my wife is ready so yeah a big
family like yours I hope so I hope so I
I could have like 10 but really her body
whatever it's her it's her decision
fans are going crazy with the rumors
that are out there have you heard
anything and I want to get this on the
record what is Brooklyn Beckham's
favorite Spice Girl song ever oh my gosh
um probably wannabe really classic yeah
that's that's probably my favorite for
what reason
um you know I was on when I was really
young I was always on tour and that was
kind of the song me and my brothers
Always Dance too so probably that one
congratulations you better open that Pub
I will
foreign